foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
all right everybody no time for nonsense
to kick off today's stream we're picking
up some of the Johnny Depp trial it's
gotten very crazy of audio taped abuse
sessions and all sorts of different
things I believe we're now hearing from
the butler if I recall correctly let's
listen let's figure it out together
occasion would I be available a to go
and manage a property where Mr Depp was
going to be staying for a about a month
in central London
was I available would I be willing to do
it and I was available at that point and
so I said yes I would yeah absolutely
and just to make sure we're on the same
page what time frame are we talking
about here that was August
um 2014.
okay
and did you in fact end up working for
Mr dupp in that time frame I did yes
now just to clarify uh were you employed
by Mr dap no so so who was your employer
uh I was paid through a large hotel
which was close by to the house who also
uh
they they
provided the housekeeper who was working
with us for that month as well so I was
paid through them
okay
and you just generally explain to us
what kind of work you were doing for Mr
duck and Miss heard in this time frame
sure yeah it was the setup of the house
basically um
sorry
setting up the house initially
which which meant ahead of the
principles arriving
which meant making sure the Linens were
in place for the veterans it was it was
a sizable property
and just organizing everything ahead of
their arrival once they arrived did he
witness the Grumpy's probably the
oversight of it and the day-to-day
running some service you know like
Butler Service and managing the
housekeeper day-to-day through that
whole month
and when you refer to the principles who
are you referring to Mr Depp and
misheard
uh where exactly were you working in
London at this point I just kind of
described for us the house this house
this was in Mayfair is a large townhouse
in an old building but it's very
contemporary inside uh modern
uh furnished very modern sort of way
um it's quite spacious maybe four or
five bedrooms I think a small indoor
pool a small gym small quite an open
plan layout throughout the house like a
huge gem okay
um and how long how long were they there
for the month essentially yes
can you tell us just generally what
hours you would typically work in a day
while you were working for them in
London in this time frame yeah
um approximately depended on what was
going on but I mean generally seven or
eight in the morning till
seven or eight in the evening typically
there was a chef employed as well
Russell brilliant Chef he um you should
see was it what he was able to do with
the mangoes but in the evening he would
cook dinner serve dinner and
thankfully cleaned up after dinner so I
I could leave sort of early to mid
evening usually most days genius Jack
unless we had guests sorry unless there
were guests or other things going on
during your time managing the house for
uh Mr Devin this heard in 2014 did you
have occasion to observe the
interactions between Mr Duff and miss
her
yes absolutely
how often
Miss daily I would say pretty much most
days through that period
and did you yourself interact with Mr
Depp and Mr yes also Daily I would say
which of them would you say or did you
see one of them more often than the
other
third was there Mr Depp was
um the reason I think they rented the
house was because Mr Depp was working at
a studio he was I think it was Mordecai
the movie
there at the house most of the days Mr
debt often went to work and came back
later on in that evening that day
uh how would you generally describe
the the
interactions That You observe between Mr
Depp and Miss heard
initially very sort of loving towards
each other you know
a nice couple
um Mr debt was always a gentleman and
and Keen to make sure miss heard was
taken care of anything she needed often
pour a glass of wine for her whoa
um just nice you know Pleasant
uh how about your own interactions with
the couple how did you get along with
them both I think very well I'm yeah I
they were really open to me and I mean
my background's quite formal so it was
that it was quite an informal setting it
was I was able to ask questions
to either of them it was heard
especially it was really helpful to get
information about what time they wanted
dinner you know basic stuff like that or
anything it was it was good interaction
all the time information with the both
of them
okay now you mentioned uh you mentioned
wine can you tell us to what extent did
You observe either of them consume
alcohol over the course of these four
weeks sure um before I when I started
that job when I was taking that job all
night yeah I was told I think by Mr
Depp's assistant that he was
hearsay all right
can you answer without telling what you
were told
I was made aware that Mr death was
here say everybody
same objection he's explaining what he's
been told now he just said I was
informed I don't think it's offered for
the truth your honor I think it's just
offered for to to explain his own
behavior towards the couple
um can we approach okay
so what's at issue here is what the
butler was told with regard to alcohol
consumption my guess is that the Amber
Heard side
uh well I don't know what let's just
wait and see what what the deal is and
why this is so problematic
my guess would be that what he was told
may have been something like keep her
away from the alcohol or something along
those lines maybe he imagine if he was
going to say well I was told she gets
extremely violent when she drinks to
keep her from the drink I I just don't
know but that's my sense of it
welcome Everybody by the way yes welcome
welcome
all right so so Mr King I'm moving past
the conversation let's not touch on that
um but just in general can you describe
the alcohol consumption that you
personally observed and what you
personally witnessed there you go
um I didn't see Mr herb Mr consuming
alcohol that during that time in London
um I I there was a large Consignment of
wine that had been delivered to the
house at the start of the visit I
couldn't sign any cases that I had to
store had to find a place to store
and
generally speaking on a day-to-day about
one or two bottles of red wine were
consumed
per day I think that's fast by her I
guess right did you ever observe Mr Depp
drink any of the wine
no I didn't right okay did you ever
observe miss her drink any of the wine
yes I did
regularly
daily
two bottles a day is a lot
no I think you already testified that
you
observed interactions with Mr Depp and
Miss heard and you generally found them
to be friendly is that fair very much so
yes
um were there any exceptions to that
towards me
I'll rephrase did you ever observe any
arguments between the two yes I did
I love this one good
man that guy's got to sit down oh yes I
did yeah okay and can you describe for
us the arguments that you observed
I can describe two of them um certainly
uh there were a few arguments on that
during that month
let's just start with those two okay
uh the first one I remember was a an
evening actually they were both the ones
I recall were and I was close to were
evenings uh this first particular
evening
the couple would do to go out for dinner
I I guess
um I know the car was waiting in the
in the little Courtyard there ready for
them to go and security were waiting to
to take them
I was waiting to see them out into the
cars at the foot of the on the ground
level ground floor level
to uh wait to see them out essentially
and I heard the first thing I heard was
misheard shouting upstairs in the master
suite where they were getting ready to
to leave I heard her shout something I
don't recall what you know I was in the
vicinity I wasn't really there to listen
and
um I Heard footsteps loud footsteps sort
of going across a there's a like a
Corridor if you like at the top of those
stairs that went around the master suite
uh loud footsteps and then more
footsteps following more shouting
and that that sort of went on for some
time I mean I I knew that they'd what
time they needed to leave I don't recall
what time that was but they
I knew they need they were supposed to
have left already and
it went on for a bit
do you recall how that first uh fight or
argument resolved
no not necessarily I mean I know that
they left eventually albeit late uh I I
don't know how I like this guy really
resolved because I sort of made myself
busy but not going too far away from the
door and make sure I saw them out
and then what about the second argument
that you mentioned
second one I was pretty much in the same
vicinity the same room on the ground
floor
again I would the couple were in the the
TV room I think which was off the main
sitting room early evening and I was
going about my
early evening duties replenishing drinks
close by
um you know like Evolution lighting
candles whatever it might have been I
was close enough to to hear Miss heard
say
why did you take your hand away from me
Johnny don't you don't you love me
anymore
like not in a playful this guy's got a
Texas accent right
um and I think he replied of course I do
don't be silly you know of course I do
and it kind of launched from that point
and at one point Mr Depp got up and went
to a bathroom or went upstairs and I was
sort of scuttering around out of the way
because I you know I wasn't there
listening I was just there doing my
stuff
in and around them
yeah it was a strange sort of banal way
to start an argument but
how would you describe Miss herd's tone
when she said
um why did you take your hand away
Johnny
accusatory spoiled teenage child
maybe is that fair whoa pretty you know
not playfully let's put it that way more
angrily
um over the course of the four weeks in
August and September 2014 when you were
working with Mr definition in London yes
did you ever observe any physical
violence of any kind between the two of
them no I didn't
did you ever observe any injuries on
either one of them no neither of them
okay after those four weeks did you ever
work for Mr Depp or misheard again I did
a couple of occasions the following year
was the first one
the following spring
okay and where was that
in Australia
and what is it uh was it unusual for you
to be in Australia
in Australia maybe but not unusual for
me to travel with for clients from my
assignments to wherever it was needed
okay
um how how exactly did it come about
that you were in Australia with Mr duck
and miss her
um towards the end of the London visit
uh Mr deput kindly said you know thanks
so much for looking after us we really
like you maybe if you're free next year
and we can arrange it we can make it
happen
perhaps you'll be able to come to
Australia with us I've got a film
Pirates five
so I said great I'd love to you know
obviously I was freelance at the time so
it was gonna be about four months work I
think it was Builders so I thought yes I
wouldn't mind some of that thank you
very much
and we're in Australia were you staying
there's a Gold Coast
it's a Brisbane area um Brisbane was the
main airport so it's about an hour's
Drive south of Brisbane
and do you recall when you arrived
I arrived on February the 4th I know I
flew on that day
okay
how did your job responsibilities in
Australia compare to your job
responsibilities uh in London much the
same just on a bigger scale the house
was larger
there was a bit more set up to do but
essentially the same oversight of the
house you know responsible for it during
the whole if my butler was ever
cross-examined I would head for the
hills guys I'm telling you right now who
were you employed by
essentially by Disney the production
company affiliated with Disney who were
making the movie I think their name was
Hershel was the production company
now I think you said you arrived in
Australia on February 4th 2015 could I
have that right yes okay uh how about Mr
Depp and Miss heard when did they arrive
and the setup for me for us was about a
few weeks I think they they arrived
towards the end of February
2015.
and between your arrival and their
arrival what had you been doing
just setting up the house I lived on
site uh there was a guest house on site
a two-bedroom single-story guest house
that I stayed in for those first couple
of weeks uh setting up the house and
just getting everything ready
during that time and then I think what
is fascinating about this trial other
than you know the the incredible obscene
wealth that's exposed through British
Butlers and all of these different
things uh and the fact that
at minimum you know this was there was
abuse going both ways to to put it kind
of agnostically I guess or neutrally so
far although that may not even be
warranted uh is that everybody's
straight out of Central Casting I mean
Johnny Depp during his testimony
essentially one of his best acting roles
I've ever seen every every movement
every expression uh the butler is
straight out of central cast and it's
truly incredible a good size house
beautiful house beautiful location
how many entrances would you say it had
entrances many I mean many on certainly
on the lower ground level out to the
Garden
um on the first or on the main floor
level there was many entrances
Depp allowed us to eat at least once
every week
every room on the lower ground floor had
had a sliding door or a door out the
utility room the garage that the gym the
every Everything uh obviously the front
door
many on the main level the large glass
sliding doors out to the pool area which
had a gazebo and and it steps down to
the to the ground
okay and once Mr Depp and Ms heard
arrived to stay at this house
um was anybody else staying in the house
staying in the house no in was anybody
else staying on the grounds on the
property yes I mean there was a couple
there can't take care taking couple uh
Sean and his wife
Sandra who worked for the the owner of
the house they lived on on site
essentially all the time they were there
pretty much throughout
um and their house was whatever a couple
of hundred yards away from the main
house
um and yes security were there all soon
all right sticking with the caretaker
just briefly
um about how long would it take would
you estimate it would take to walk from
the main house to the caretaker's house
under five minutes I mean yeah minutes
no more than five minutes wow okay
and then you mentioned security what was
the security set up security was set up
um by Jerry judge
they they were employed they stayed in
the grounds for the duration they didn't
come into the house they had a little
sort of Shack where ground by the
perimeter
where they would do that start their
patrols from walk around the grounds of
around the exterior of the house at
certain times of the day write their
reports and
go back and stay in their their Shack
and how many security guards would be on
site at any particular time I think one
in the day and one in the night so they
did 12 hours about as I remember it but
it was 24 7. yes definitely
uh do you know whether those were were
local employees or were they regularly
important I believe they were they were
Australian yes
now I think you said you were not it was
a ghastly 1200 square foot Shack correct
yeah I I kept the same hours as I
did in London essentially you know
Monday to Friday night to five not quite
but seven eight a.m till evening till
everything was set up and I could leave
and did you have an opportunity when you
were in Australia
um to observe Mr Depp and mrd's
interactions with each other yes of
course
and how would you describe them
initially very good like in London it
seemed very
Pleasant towards each other
Did You observe any arguments yes I've
several
okay can you tell us a little bit about
those
um yes a similar patent it seemed to
London arguments
uh one in particular was
very similar to the the second one in
London quite jarring uh started in a
in the TV room funnily enough
um loud loud voices
and Mr Depp leaving the room
shutting the door going to another room
to play his guitar or you know to a
bathroom whatever
um and miss her closely following him
opening the door or certainly wrapping
on the door elements of bathrooms it
seemed to continue
giving us an estimate
um about how many arguments you think he
observed in this time frame
approximately several I mean we were
there for several months so certainly
many more than in London
Did You observe any alcohol consumption
in Australia by either of them
yes again misheard
um I was again my response part of my
responsibilities was to provision the
house and have everything set up for
that so I I regularly brought red wine
for misheard
which she consumed you know the same
same amount as in London I think and
what about is that he's speaking
one or two bottles a day
wow
did you ever observe uh Mr Depp start
any arguments with miss her
no so hold on oh sorry yeah could you
put your record there we go objection
how sustain is the leading if you want
I'll we can move on good question okay
um
do you remember anything about uh Friday
March couldn't you say did you notice
any pattern to the initiator of the
arguments so it's more neutral
essentially a normal Friday if you like
um end of the week yay
um nothing extraordinary about that day
did you come into the into work that day
yes yeah I was there yeah okay
um do you recall about what time you
would have left the house uh on that
date I remember taking a photo of a of a
beautiful sunset over the pool the sun
would set over the pool and the creek
I took a photo of that around early
evening so 6 37 I would think I wouldn't
have left much later than that
was Mr gupp there when you left
I don't think so I think Mr dett was at
the studio still
on that day I can't remember sort of
seeing him to say goodbye now you know
have a good weekend
how about Mr do you recall if she was
there when you left yes she was
okay did anything unusual happen that
weekend
yeah
I would say something pretty unusual
happened
can you tell us about that
yeah I can Foundation
all right foundation you only have
Foundation at some point did you become
aware that something had happened
between yesterday
all right hearsay assisting that
objection okay let's see how he works
around turning to the following Sunday
how much more do you have time for her
after
uh I think we can
I have I have a little bit more honestly
I think maybe this could be a good time
for everyone all right let's go ahead
and take our afternoon 15 minute break
ladies and gentlemen again do not talk
to me all right so they're building up
to a particular incident here now I'll
tell you guys I I am primarily
interested in this as an observer of
high-profile trials
as a personal interest thing about how
others are reacting to it there are
people who feel very strongly that oh
I'm sorry hold on a second if we are
going to break by the way
by the way El zones pizza is here in
fact we have Subway tomorrow the food is
here let's take a break lunch is here
warm food around noon whatever you do
make sure you go to the bathroom
somewhere other than the cartwheel okay
so having admonished everybody properly
with regard to that
um there are lots of people who are just
emailing me saying Amber Heard is the
abuser here
and the abuser there's a very there's an
uphill battle because it is assumed that
in this case the man more than 20 years
older is obviously the abuser but in
this case many people emailing me saying
it's not the case I don't feel as though
I've seen enough of this to make such a
definitive statement I think what I've
seen enough to know the relationship was
insane
they weren't particularly good to each
other in some general sense they both
seem to have serious issues including
substance abuse Johnny Depp maybe not so
much alcohol but other drugs and Amber
Heard
maybe more alcohol
um and as far as from what a jury would
find I'm reading that the jury is
finding Johnny Depp very sympathetic
so okay I I think that that's kind of my
view right now is someone who doesn't
pretend to have seen every every minute
of this so I think I think we can leave
it at that
um they're going to be back in just a
few minutes so we'll continue I do plan
to stream Tonight Tonight is the
Pennsylvania
Republican
Senate debate with Mehmet Oz who is a
medical doctor although he sometimes
recommends drinking silver he is a
medical doctor he is one of the
candidates I do plan to cover that
tonight what might prevent me from doing
so is if that we can't find a stream of
the debate there's a bunch of local news
stations covering that tonight and
unfortunately local news stations are
very litigious when it comes to
copyright so I'm gonna think about I'm
going to think about the best way to
cover it and I hope to cover it and be
back later they they're probably only
going another hour here so we'll cover
the rest of this I do want to thank
everybody who has dropped in a twitch
Prime subscription today that includes
Patty McNinja Graham sassanuck Jen here
living Aaron and Polo Dao I also want to
thank some incredible people these these
people deserve the the presidential
medal of freedom who have signed up on
my website Robert Smith is a new member
on my website and is number six we've
also gotten a new gifted subscription
from Kevin gouldy Felicia Barrera
Felicia Felicia Felicia Judah Diaz and
Melissa tarnoff each of them gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com and that
puts us at number 10 I should give away
I I have to announce sorry I wasn't
prepared for so many gifts dumping in
um let me announce
who gets those four gifted subscriptions
while we are in a break here those four
go to oh hold on I'm sorry I'm just
let's see here Bryce Wright Quinn
Jacobson Tessa Gibson and oh wait no
Robert got one over and no that's the
wrong one too
all done
oh no that's not
we're almost there
Catherine Logue Catherine Logue is the
fourth person getting a free membership
today if you don't have a membership get
one at joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code Obama Obama if you have a
membership and you want to gift one to
somebody else you still go to
joinpakman.com but you check that this
is a gift box as you check out
um
Penn Live will be streaming tonight
maybe use their stream okay I'll look
into that hey does anybody know what
time the Pennsylvania debate is tonight
thanks viewer Andy by the way for the
twitch Prime subscription anybody know
what time the Pennsylvania Senate debate
is tonight
thought it was 8 pm
Pennsylvania Republican Senate debate
April 25 2022
when is this thing let's see here
oh God I'm getting blocked out of
everywhere from my ad blocker
it will only be an hour oh 8 P.M okay so
my plan is I will no no it can't be 7 PM
it says everywhere that it's 8 pm
everything I'm seeing is 8 PM anyway
I'll start a half hour before the debate
whenever it is and I believe that it's
at 8 pm we'll get it figured out between
now and then I do have I haven't added
these to my soundboard yet but our great
friend small fuzzy Moss who's
responsible for about 80-ish percent of
the different clips I have on my
soundboard
sent me some great new clips from the
Saturday night Trump rally it's
unbelievable the Treasure Trove of clips
that we got from the Trump went on a
five-minute toilet rant and so listen to
some of these uh some of these that we
got and I won't talk about the third
element of the bathroom because every
time I do the fake news only talks about
that yep
and I won't talk about the third element
of the bathroom okay
one time two times five times ten times
no water comes out because that's Trump
flushing and you can do that other thing
normally all right the third element of
the bathroom yeah
okay he's walking around somewhat
bewildered
no idea what the hell is happening okay
so I got gas yep and then last no
teacher should ever be allowed to teach
transgender transgender okay
um so that was just a crazy crazy crazy
stream and we're gonna get a lot of
those adopted into our
repertoire very very soon thanks to Jody
bundrick for donating subscription
number 12 the lucky recipient is Sarah
schmeltzer Sarah schmeltzer
congratulations you get a free
subscription I really appreciate that uh
other news yes so Elon Musk is buying
Twitter
has accepted Elon musk's buyout deal
Twitter's board accepted billionaire
Elon musk's offer to buy the social
media company and take it private full
disclosure I own no Twitter stock other
than through I assume mutual funds
I don't know the announcement ends a
weeks-long saga musk kicked off when he
offered to buy the company at 54.20 per
share that was his best and final
Twitter's board sought to fend off a
hostile takeover by adopting a so-called
poison pill Twitter reacting quite
positively to the news shares up five
close to six percent so that's a very
very big deal and you know I get all
these people who are constantly wanting
me to stake out some kind of black and
white position on Elon Musk my view on a
lot of these big Tech CEOs
is sort of like my view of politicians I
don't idolize or demonize almost anybody
unless like they really really deserve
it as many of you know I've owned Tesla
stock back since 2015 I drive a Tesla
the car's fine you know I'm not like oh
my God this is what you got a Hyundai
ionic oh go to prison you know or you
know like lawsuit we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines okay
no I don't that I don't care about that
it's like the cars are fine there's no
doubt that Tesla accelerated the
development of long-range electric
vehicles dramatically that's great and
Elon Musk also tweets stupid [ __ ] all
the time that I disagree with
um what I don't love is a few people
owning every big company
that seems like a problem for me I don't
I don't like that but the whole thing of
musk is evil he's a savior there's all
these Fanboys it's like
I've learned that when Elon Musk sets
his mind to doing something it's very
hard to get him not to do it betting
against him seems dumb based on a track
record and at the same time
he says so many dumb things and and
creates problems and says stuff I don't
agree with Bill Gates what Bill Gates
did in terms of the personal Computing
Revolution and Steve Jobs and I I'm not
taking any sides is incredible and also
Bill Gates you know with
the monopolistic elements of Microsoft
and all these things are the props so so
it's let's let's all just relax a little
bit it's sort of like oh but we pray at
the altar of Tulsi or Bernie or no all
of that stuff nobody is is a hundred
percent anything
um yeah and maybe what he's gonna do is
we'll destroy Twitter who know who knows
I don't know I don't have any idea I'm
not a Twitter investor I just don't know
okay and Wozniak and everybody everybody
I know everybody we're not ignoring
anybody here
um okay
let's see let's listen to just a couple
of voicemails as we continue waiting for
the resumption here's the Eggman
weighing in
hey Dave
a guy at the Trump rallies
seen Jerry Garcia tons and tons of times
and you know Trump rally is better than
the Detroit smells better
um Dave I've seen the Grateful Dead
maybe a hundred times maybe more
um all of Jerry Garcia
you wouldn't believe it but there is a
right-wing chunk of deadheads and when
we use the mail order our tickets we
would um mail in our tickets every
single summer so we would sit in the
same section the whole entire Summer
Long like 20 shows 30 shows the whole
summer is the Eggman okay he's got a
really annoying throat clearing thing
going on hope it's not coveted it's one
section in front of Phil in in the front
of philzone with all these right-wing
Republican dudes with like what Izod
polo shirts and of course killer [ __ ]
weed and it was really weird and we
would have discussion political
discussion left-wing or right wing and I
couldn't believe Republicans were there
but these people were not as crazy
as a trumpers today that are telling you
I still have flags up we did have a
political discourse we discussed stuff
back then there are right-wing deadheads
not very many but there are Shalom
brother all right well Shalom very very
interesting
um Whitney checking in it's been a while
since we heard from her
but I think a lot of men make such small
moves but it's like hard to really
detect
um exactly what they're doing unless you
like you know
um just like
hit and watch like life go by which is
what I've been doing a lot um a lot of
men do who make really small moves and
all right and then Eric from Mass
weighing in as well
yeah David it's better for math uh what
came to someone says is absolutely right
I told you the guy uh doctor I have
explained the whole thing to me if you
want to know details proof or evidence
just contact me right I mean evidently
you don't because I've asked you to do
that several times yeah no I typically
don't call viewers on the phone yeah uh
you can email me at uh whoa okay all
right I don't even know let's
let's just get away from that that
doesn't that seems like a bad direction
to go on on the show so let's not even
do that I want to say thanks to Betsy
cook Betsy just gifted a subscription at
joinpakman.com the lucky recipient is
Jacob oh wait no that one we did already
I'm sorry let me get to the right one
these are like in a weird order
let me just see here
Brad Ray is the lucky recipient of the
next free subscription if you would like
a free subscription just enter your name
at davidpackman.com free membership we
currently have 695 people waiting for
free memberships significant demand
significant demand so we're going to
look at that very very strongly let's
see if I have any other
voicemails for people let's do like a
normal voicemail
so my dad got adopted from England
and
um when the Germans found him his name
was like uh Phillips oh well okay we
don't want to dox Whitney's dad that
seems like a bad idea let's keep going
[Music]
interview that um
David did with um Jr I can't pronounce
his last name from Ohio
Majewski I thought it was a really good
interview because
you know
um we do need to talk both sides but I
would have been interested to hear what
type
um or not what type but what
um news
um stations
this fellow watches Fox News yeah
welcome to uh tyt thank you for the raid
over on Twitch tyt has rated us we're
listening to audience voicemails and in
about five minutes uh Johnny Depp and
Amber heard's Butler will continue to be
asked he is getting to a critical moment
in the testimony which we are
fascinating with great following with
great interest also tonight
um around 8 PM Eastern I'll be covering
the Mehmet Oz Republican Pennsylvania
Senate debate if you look at oh let's
let's actually do that
270 to win if you look right now
at the Senate Maps
one of the things you see in is that in
just about every map so here's the 2022
consensus map Pennsylvania is a toss-up
if you look at Larry sabato's Crystal
Ball Pennsylvania is a toss-up if you
look at the cook political map
Pennsylvania is a toss-up if you look at
inside elections Pennsylvania is leaning
red if you look at Politico it's a
toss-up if you uh okay well that's it so
the point here is Mehmet Oz versus John
fetterman if they are the the winners of
their respective primaries could
determine the balance of power in the
Senate starting in January of 2023 so
it's an incredibly important incredibly
important race and that's why we will be
covering the debate tonight and I hope
that you're there with us let's listen
to a couple of other
uh voicemails here
phone numbers
202. oh my God okay are you nuts no no
no no no no no no no no no no no oh my
God
what I don't even know if that woman has
marjories what what the hell do people
think this is this is not maybe those
types of shows exist but
dear God please don't call in and give
people uh people's cell phones oh my God
we have people from tyt here and this is
what I'm playing it's humiliating let's
listen to uh something else
hi David
[Music]
um I couldn't help but
respond to the eggman's take on you
being asked to provide some information
about what certain Yiddish words mean
um I am a boomer I'm a cisgender
straight college educated woman so in a
lot of ways I am a person of privilege
whoa and so I can only speak from that
perspective
but in terms of asking you to Define
certain Yiddish words I don't feel like
it's any different uh from asking
um a person that I know from France what
certain French words might mean yeah I
think it's fine I said I think it's fine
um as I said before you know if somebody
needs me to explain what a shtickle of
fluoride is you know the Seinfeld fans
will get that one I think it's fine
um people are saying Elon Musk bought
Twitter yeah we we so he didn't buy it
yet they've reached an agreement to use
the financing he has put together to
take it private so even the people
saying Elon just bought Twitter or wrong
we've already spoken about it we've
already spoken about it and it's a very
very interesting thing
uh okay a couple of other voice I have
no way of limited time before they
return
but let's just see
what else we have uh
let's see uh hello David
um Pac-Man uh I'm just wondering if um
for the past two to three weeks I have
thrown out to YouTube
and I have noticed something
um at the majority report
um
it seems like Sam secret is m.i.e
there's no discussion about his
mysterious
um
disappearance hey so is that true do
people oh okay okay okay okay I I wasn't
sure if Sam what oh no Sam was public
that he had covered yeah all right I was
like I don't want to I don't want to say
anything that's not known but right
right right okay yeah Sam Sam has covet
or had covet that's all that's going on
he announced that it sounds like he's
going to be fine and we are getting back
to it here okay so let's let's listen
sorry thank you
critical moment here
in the trial
yeah welcome everybody every people are
coming in they're like am I allowed here
everybody's allowed okay come on in
come on
Elon wants to crack down on Bots says
Bay photo but don't the creators of Elon
crypto scambots that reply to all his
tweets have free speech too right well
said
well said this is the butler for those
um just joining us
welcome to Caleb Hunter Caleb just got a
membership on my website and is number
14 today thanks Caleb uh and thanks to
everybody re-upping their twitch Prime
subscriptions as well
guys everything's welcome everything's
welcome just everybody everybody's
welcome here okay
Sam was back today oh good okay good I
didn't know that
I was texting with him the other day
I said because he got coveted I'm gonna
destroy my panels which I stole from him
just as a sign of good faith
very respectful Butler
see your next question sir
professionally trained
Mr King uh yes before we went on break
we were discussing uh
Friday March 6 2015. right
um after you left
uh the house that evening
when did you when did you next see Miss
heard
Sunday the 8th
and where did you see Mr
at the house
what were your typical hours
Monday to Friday from seven or eight a.m
until
the end of play each evening early
evening usually
why were you at the house that Sunday
I was called to the house by one of Mr
Depp's assistants
and about what time
did you arrive at the house
around 2 o'clock 2 30.
who was there when you arrived
foreign
Debbie Lloyd was there
David Kipper was there
[Music]
Amber Heard was there
Jerry George was there
and I think I think by now probably
everybody's familiar but can you just
very quickly say who those who those
people are sure uh Debbie Lloyd was a
nurse
David Kipper was Dr David Kipper
Miss heard was misheard and Jerry judge
was head of security
and when you arrived at the house on
Sunday March 8th 2015. uh what did you
do
I just pumped up and went into the house
and Did You observe anything when you
went into the house
yeah I mean initially I walked into the
front door initially I heard rather than
saw anything I could hear pretty
hysterical sobbing crying
um which sounded like misheard to me
I heard Jerry judge's voice
there's a few steps as you go up into
the house so you can't immediately see
um what's going on but so I went up the
steps I could see then misheard over on
the right hand side of towards the TV
room with Jerry Judge David Kipper was
in the kitchen area which was pretty
much directly ahead as you walk up those
steps
and were you able to visually see
misheard
yes
and you were able to hear her as well
absolutely
how would you describe her demeanor
hysterical probably the best way to
describe it um
crying a lot and
you know
just just crying uncontrollably I think
it's fair to say
and how would you describe uh Jerry
judge's demeanor when he was speaking
with her
he was just keeping her calm saying it's
all right love it will be all right
Jerry was good like he had a big heart
Jerry he's a good guy he was he he was
calm Jerry was always calm well mostly
and what did you do next
um I saw they were engaged across away
there so I went into the main kitchen
area which as I said was just directly
ahead of those main steps and spoke to
David Kipper
and following that conversation what did
you do
well he told me that
um Mr Depp had objection hearsay all
right nice uh your honor is well maybe
approach okay
clearly a critical moment this incident
that they're referring to
thanks to digenbear for the twitch Prime
subscription
this is just stream one of two today
we'll we'll be covering the Mehmet Oz
Republican loony debate tonight from the
Pennsylvania Senate I expect it to be
uh quite weaponized for lack of a better
term
no word on what Johnny Depp is chewing
on looks like it could be a a bag of
nuts potentially
sort of unclear
I don't know how many more days this is
going to go on but it certainly feels
like we're not anywhere even remotely
close to the end not even remotely close
I would guess we're not even halfway
through to be perfectly Frank
all right here we go
so you can answer the question what did
you do next
so I spoke to David Kepler who was in
the kitchen area
seemingly rummaging through a bin
um he said he was that as the depth had
sustained an injury to his finger one of
his fingers and he was looking for a
the fingertip that it said it had been
severed
so I said I said well should I help you
you know as one would and he said yeah
that would be a good idea I left him in
the kitchen he said there was a lot a
lot more damage downstairs so I I went
to you know we split up he was left him
in the kitchen I went downstairs
to search
at some point was Mr Depp's fingertip
found
yes who found it
I did
and where did you find it
downstairs in that the bar area the
um
the games room area
so can you
walk us through
how you found it
yes so I walked down the stairs uh I
mean there was a bit of damage down the
steps the big chunk have been taken out
of the marble staircase on my way down
remnants of what looked like a plant pot
or something around it smashed
walking down into the bar I could see
the damage that Dr Kipper had told me
about
a broken ping pong table sort of
collapsed onto the floor and lots of
glass and broken glass and
cans strewn around the bar area
and where exactly was the finger in the
bar area
directly below the path I mean the bar
to set up like a conventional bar that
stuck out from a wall and with a marble
top it was a big chunk out of that as
well like on the staircase
directly at the end of the bar
there was a scrunched up piece of
kitchen paper if you like tissue with
lots of blood around it on it
so I thought that was probably a pretty
good place to look
and it was within that scrunched up
piece of paper on the tiled floor at the
end of the bar the base of the bar by
one of the bar stools
was there any property damaged around
the finger
yes a fair bit on the floor around the
area the puddles of what smelt like
alcohol to me there were
seemed like several drinking glasses a
couple of bottles one was the stolik
Naya vodka bottle
um
I I know it is Stoli but Stolichnaya is
an interesting one out of the bar itself
the marble top
uh at the end of that the bar
there was plaster damage right at the
end of the bar on the wall uh behind the
bar smashed and cracked
mirror there's a blue mirror that
stretched that whole span of behind the
bar
lots of cans again behind the bar on the
floor broken window at the end of the
bar and more plastered work damage on
the wall above the sink is sort of a
kitchenette bar if you like as well
you mentioned uh
bottle of vodka was the vodka bottle
intact
no
no nothing was really intact with the
top of it
you know the top of a bottle is like it
had a label on it which is how I knew it
as a stolic and eye bottle we had that
sort of squiggly yes
um sort of yellow top
there was a large chunk of a bottle
which I guess was the rest of that and
several other I mean lots of other
broken glass around the area
after you found the fingertip in the bar
area what did you do next
well I gathered it up in that kitchen
paper and sort of took it upstairs I
might have shouted up to David Kipper I
found it um I'm not sure but I I walked
back upstairs to the kitchen
and
put it got a bag you know a little um
little plastic bag put the fingertip in
there set it on top of some ice
in in this plastic kitchen container and
pretty much handed it over to David
Kipper and Jerry judge I think at the
time who were Keen to get it to the
hospital quickly
to see if it could be reattached
do you recall about what time you found
Mr Depp's finger in the bar area is
about an hour after I got there so it
would have been around 3 30 I would
think 3 20 3 30.
wow
now you've told us a little bit about
the state the house was in when you
arrived yes
um
can you generally describe for us and
maybe go level by level through the
house
um
what damage you observed
sure do you want me to start at the
lower ground floor in that bar area I
mean I've described a lot of that sure
it was pretty extensive down there all
that broken glass the blood a lot of
blood drips across that floor is a kind
of cream-colored child floor can you
imagine in that whole games area as I
said the ping pong table was collapsed
blood drips across the floor and around
the bar
and the damage on the walls as I said
the plaster work at the end of the bar
behind the bar
and the the chunk out of the marble top
so on the ground that was the
predominant damage in that in that area
on that level on the next floor on the
main floor where David Kipper was
in be in the kitchen itself again
few broken glasses and cans on the floor
suda cans behind the kitchen island The
Chef's kitchen island a liquid puddles
there's a sitting room with a couch on a
cream-colored couch which had a fair
amount of blood drips on the cushions
and
that you know that was obvious
the TV which was directly in front of
that wall mounted TV was cracked with it
seemed like a remnants of a coffee cup
embedded in some of it and the rest was
below looked like coffee splattered
behind and underneath
the TV and on the floor as well
through there we'd set up an art studio
so a lot of the art materials from that
you know paint brushes paint
various art materials were on the floor
a lot of paint on the floor blood
dripped throughout that area as well
it's especially over the it was a vast
sort of wooden parquet floor there was a
lot of oil paint and blood drips
um up to the staircase in one of the
bedrooms there were two bedrooms off of
off of the main kitchen area one of
those bedrooms had blood drips on the
duvet and a lamp had
seemingly been broken the shade was
removed
uh there were a couple of lampshades in
that in the art studio area
um on the floor
uh that was about the extent of the
damage going upstairs to the next level
there was
a few blood smears on on the wall and I
don't think Johnny Depp is sleeping but
it's certainly not impossible oh no he
just moved no idea
um and so that's the top floor was the
master
bedroom pasta Suite floor and two
bedrooms also up there
um
outside the master bedroom there was
damage to the plus to work on the on a
pillar outside maybe he is sleeping
um blood drips into the master bedroom
across the master bedroom floor
going into the master bathroom
um there was
there was a his and hers sinks and a
mirror a large mirror above each of the
sinks that had writing on on each of
them
uh again that one of the bedrooms or
both of the bedrooms I think had blood
on the duvet
covers
um and another lamp was broken Mr Depp's
guitar was in one of those bedrooms
but the bloodstained guitar
um his iPad was standing up on
one of the beds
in in one of those bedrooms
that's I mean that's about the extent of
it
that's the damage on each level yeah
[Music]
whose job was it to clean all that up
that was mine it was my
my responsibility of the house was
essentially my responsibility
so you were familiar were you familiar
with the damage generally throughout the
house I got a pretty good idea as I
walked around and saw it Oh yes
Did You observe any damaged phones
no
uh Did You observe any damage to a wall
where a phone might have been ripped off
the wall yeah
pleading
maybe the next
one was there any artwork in this house
decorating the house
the owners had left their art in the
house yes uh the Mr dab and misheard had
done some artwork themselves yes but yes
there were some that came with the house
if you like focusing just on the artwork
that came with the house
um Did You observe any damage to any of
that no nothing that I needed to repair
or replace certainly not thank goodness
is there any other damage that comes to
mind
just a lot of blood and a lot of repairs
the floor as I said it was
um quite heavily
with blood and paint
yeah
and in in terms of bodily fluids it was
just blood that you observed no urine or
anything else yes absolutely
strike for the answer from the records
oh no other damage does any other damage
come to mind no
no grumpies take a look at uh defendants
exhibit 375 which I believe is already
in evidence
and can we publish this to the journey
okay
okay
Mr King are you familiar with the image
that's on the screen in front of you
uh yes that's one of the mirrors I was
telling you about in the master bathroom
and so were you involved in cleaning any
of this up
I cleaned both of those mirrors that at
some point that that evening that night
yes
were you able to tell what was used or
what what substance the I guess what
sort of the ink is that's used on the on
the black writing there
that was the the same
um oil paint that was on the floor on
the parquet floor downstairs and various
other places was the same oil paint
all right how about the Red Riding that
says call call Carly Simon she said it
better babe
were you able to tell what was used to
make that writing a lipstick I believe
Foundation
unique projection Foundation he's
testified that he was cleaning it up
I'll allow it that's fine it certainly
seemed like lipstick to me red lipstick
it was quite waxy I remember taking that
off
um it seemed like lipstick
we can take that down
Mr King about how long were you at the
house on on that Sunday
quite a long time
um it actually went into the early hours
of Monday morning so at least I got
there around two in the afternoon of
Sunday
I don't think I left there until two or
three o'clock the next morning of the
night
over the course of the time that you
were there that day
did you have any interactions with Miss
heard yes I certainly did you describe
those for us please
yes uh not too much initially she was
very as I said quite hysterical and
crying a lot and Jerry judge was taken
care of of her keeping her calm
uh later in the evening
it was it was suggested that miss her go
to a local hotel
to to leave the house go to a local
hotel which then became a suggestion
that she'd go back to LA and that's I
think when I started interacting
um in terms of at some point I
volunteered to to travel with her to L.A
why does she need someone to travel with
her how did Miss heard respond to the
suggestion that she leave uh Los Angeles
leave for Los Angeles
she was resistant to both of those
suggestions very resistant she really
didn't want to go and said I can't leave
I can't leave you know it'll be the end
if I leave
um those sorts of things
and so it was just it it these went went
over a few hours
um those negotiations if you like
and eventually
misheard agreed that I would fly with
her
and Stitch you in fact fly with her I
did on Monday the 9th okay
sticking with Sunday
um
when you were interacting with her on on
that Sunday
um were you how close were you to her
very clear you know like very close in
front of her
and do you recall observing any injuries
on this herd no none whatsoever
did you notice anything unusual about
her physically at all
no that I mean she was obviously crying
a lot red eyes and
um but no otherwise no
okay
so what happened the following day that
that Monday uh March 9th I guess it
would be 2015. right so I mean it was
eventually agreed that I would fly with
Miss hurt so I I had to at some point go
back to my apartment drive to my
apartment to pick up my passport which
funnily enough I hadn't brought with me
um and some clothes you know a bag to
take
so I think I I left the house early
hours as I said two three may have been
a bit later a.m I drove back to my
apartment which was 30 minutes Drive
South
picked up those things I mean I didn't
know what I was how long I was going to
go for but I knew I was traveling so
passport quick shower pick up a bag of
Clues and I drove back up to the house
um
I I don't recall exactly what time I
arrived there but I know we had to leave
all the arrangements will be made by the
travel agent and Jerry judge was
liaising with them to make the flight
arrangements which I believe was going
mid mid to late morning
um
so I think we had to leave the house
around seven or eight a.m that morning
Monday the 9th
and did you travel to the airport
witness herd yes we yes we were driven
how would you describe her demeanor that
morning
um calm down a fair bit
um
she was mostly on the phone to be honest
for for pretty much the whole of that
car Journey
to various people one of which I believe
was Mr death
do you recall her saying anything on the
ride to the airport about what had
happened the night prior nothing really
just mentioned in that as well as an
explanation now
what happens when you got to the airport
if anything
we were running a bit late but I I
remember that
um luckily we were traveling first class
so the driver knew to to pull up to a
a kind of VIP for one of a better word
VIP check-in Point
um and so the car got pretty close to
where the desk was
still on the phone
and so we'd sat there for a bit with the
driver and and
misheard was talking
I don't know who to at that point
and I was thinking oh we need to make
this flight actually pretty soon because
we were already running a bit late
so I decided to go in maybe I can go in
checking our bags ahead and then come
back and get misheard she should be
finished by then which is what I did
and did you eventually get on the plane
eventually we did it was a close call to
be honest
once you were on the plane
um
did you have any conversations with Mr
yes I mean not not initially which took
some time in the bathroom she was on the
phone again to the point where the cabin
crew had to sort of tap on the door and
say uh we need to leave now God what he
needs to sit down I've been around this
type of stuff on flight there's there's
a level of entitlement that is very
annoying I just had a crazy one but this
isn't about me being luckily as I said
we were flying first class which was
lovely she was in the windows seat like
I think it was 1a1b window seat I had
the aisle seat
and finally
we could both sit down and
um in way of conversation wasn't a great
deal to be honest I did sort of say
finally so what happened you know
obviously referring to the house
and
I mean she didn't give much explanation
if any she did say
um
and have you ever been so angry with
someone you just lost it with them
um and I sort of said uh no actually I'm
pretty calm you know
even tempered guy
um but she did repeat it she looked
pretty incredulous that I hadn't and she
repeated it you mean you've never lost
it
with somebody who got so angry with
someone you just lost it with them
and I said unless you count the sort of
time when I was 14 years old and I hit
the light switch in my bedroom because I
wasn't allowed out that night or
something with a person no never never
and that was pretty much the end of the
conversation that was it
how would you describe her tone when she
asks those questions have you to me are
you incredulous be fair to say you've
never cut someone's finger off
stick with somebody
does anything else stand out about that
flight
it was fairly car after that it was calm
but I mean we were both exhausted
um
guy certainly was and
I think I can't remember eating even
just slept most of the flight
um until obviously we landed or close to
Landing
at any point Did You observe anything
about Miss heard physically on that
flight
yes I did it right toward just before we
landed I noticed some marks on her on
her arm her left
forearm that's how he described this
um long
kind of uniform evenly spaced sort of
long thin
marks
very uniform in fact
and when did you first notice those
on the plane did towards coming into
land you know we're Gathering the stuff
up I noticed them then
what did you do after you landed in Los
Angeles
once I fired up my phone on Landing
uh I saw the arrangements that we would
be picked up by one of Mr Depp's
security Personnel who I I think was
Travis mcgiven McGovern mcgiven
um
so I made contact with him and he met us
in the place that had been arranged we
walked through the you know the arrivals
lounge and met him at the end of that
got in the car with him and uh drove to
the Eastern Columbia building
and how did Miss heard how would you
describe Miss heard's demeanor in Los
Angeles
yeah we're pretty calm I mean
um
she seemed I mean obviously a lot calmer
from the house but uh she's Pleasant
towards Travis certainly in the car
obviously they knew each other
um
she was we when we got to the building
she was kind enough to show me around
the the apartment I'd never been before
she showed me around the penthouse
little tour she wrote down some
restaurants recommendations
because she knew I'd be staying a few
days probably so and I didn't I don't
really know L.A that well
so she recommended a few restaurants
um I and then I I left I said if you
need anything as usual as I always did
need anything give me a shout I'll be
staying fairly close by
just just give me a call or a text
how long were you in LA
uh less than a week I think I flew back
to Australia on the 14th or 15th
serve about five days six days tops
and when you got back to Australia what
were you doing
pretty much putting the house back
together
repairing all the damage with the help
of professional contractors vendors
brought in and just getting the house
back
as it as it was originally
at some point did Mr Depp and Miss heard
return to Australia yes earlier
um were you there when they when they
returned yes
Did You observe them interacting with
each other after they came back to
Australia yes yeah
and how would you describe their
interactions again initially those first
few days were certainly very pleasant
almost honeymoon like I would say
um it strolled around the grounds a bit
and
they've seen seemed fine with each other
did you ever observe any arguments after
they returned but yes I mean many
and several more yeah
and how would you describe those
uh not dissimilar to the London
arguments in terms of the pattern of
those
um
you know the sort of provocation and the
reaction that leave the room Mr that
leaving room going to another room
playing his guitar
seem to follow the same pattern as that
um as I witnessed those two times in
London
all right
nothing further all right
crosstimination
here we go
good afternoon good afternoon
um so to understand your testimony is it
your testimony that Amber and Mr Depp
arrived together in Australia in
February of 2015. initially I together I
don't think so I think Mr Depp arrived
ahead of Mr Smith actually Mr duck
arrived first correct I think so yeah
and isn't it true that it's heard
amberden arrived until March 5th 2015 to
Australia I can't remember the date she
arrived to be honest but she could have
arrived March 5th 2015 isn't that true
production Foundation speculation ah
loud if you can answer it
sorry what was the question Miss heard
could have arrived on March 5th 2015
correct
I suppose and isn't it true then that
you didn't see any arguments between
Miss heard and Mr death before the
injury that occurred to Mr def's finger
in Australia
I saw the Magi you saw them argue when
they came back when they came back in
April correct
I certainly saw them argue in April and
through most of the months they were
there but you but you don't remember you
can't recall any arguments in February
or March of 2015 between Miss heard and
Mr dad well if she wasn't there till
March
not necessarily no right so that you
don't know you can't say that there were
any arguments before you came to the
house on March 8th 2015 correct I think
they were I mean
excuse me say that again I think there
were
but you don't even know when she arrived
correct
specifically the day uh not necessarily
no okay
and you said when you arrived at the
house on March 8th
um when you eventually found you guys
see the lawyer just signal him right
wrapped I mean it was Loosely wrapped
he's just gotta stay calm this guy seems
honest to me and it was sitting in in
the sort of nest of this paper yeah so
like someone had put the finger in a
piece of paper I I I don't know I mean
it was in that piece of paper it wasn't
a piece of paper Okay so but again like
someone had wrapped it up is that right
I don't know it was within that
scrunched up piece of paper kitchen
paper tissues it was in kitchen paper I
think it was just sort of like a stay
calm and take your time type signal a
lot of blood on it it's like a paper
towel like a piece of kitchen towel
towel our language is made even though
we both speak English I may stay a
little different it's like a paper towel
um you get like kitchen paper kitchen
towel yes okay like a tissue and was
there that sort of paper towel in the in
the kitchen at the house at the time yes
in both in areas of the kitchen and the
in the bar
um
you said you were in
um Australia starting in February of
2015 correct correct I arrived on the
4th of February and Mr Depp arrived
sometime after that is that right
correct okay
did you see
um Marilyn Manson while you were there
no I didn't you don't know if Mr Depp
was with Marilyn Manson in early late
February early March 2015. objection
Foundation to speculation relevance I'm
just asking if you thought if he he said
he saw how he stays home every day so I
was asking I'll allow the question if
you can answer it that's fine
Marilyn Manson didn't come to the house
I couldn't see him at any point do you
know if Mr dapp left to be with Marilyn
Manson I don't know I didn't always know
where he was going if he was went out it
was either to work or the security would
go with I wouldn't generally go
in fact I don't think I went out with
him at all in Australia and there you
didn't go out with Mr Deb at all when he
was in Australia correct I didn't recall
it I went to I saw him on set once or
twice yeah so you don't know what Mr
Depp was doing in Australia
unless he was unless you saw him at the
house or unset is that right
I saw him at the house yes every day but
you don't know what he Mr Depp was doing
when he left the house correct generally
going to work on Pirates of the
Caribbean five films yes were you were
with him
about the security with him and I had to
liaise with him for when they would go
and when he would come back for the
driver Etc but you weren't there you
weren't there when Mr left the house
correct generally I didn't go didn't
leave the house with Mr Depp on those
days no and I just want to make sure I
want to be clear there were there were
two kind of periods that Mr Depp was in
Australia in 2015. I am genuinely
curious if and how they're going to poke
holes in what seems like a very honest
guy story 2015 until
about March 8th March 9th when he
injured his finger is that right correct
yeah and then Mr Depp left Australia too
correct
at some point yes and then Mr Depp
returned to Australia on April 21st
right okay that sounds about that time I
don't know the specific date I don't
recall and the filming of Pirates of the
Caribbean five continued filming on
April 21st right objection Foundation
speculation I didn't know his objection
you recall testifying for that in the UK
that
the filming of Pirates of Caribbean 5
continued filming on April 21st 2015.
I wasn't involved in the filming
schedule I I didn't know what when it
resumed to be honest I knew Mr Depp to
come back to resume filming for sure
you can live with Mr Depp in his house
in Australia correct live with the no I
wasn't resident there
now when you arrived at the house
you saw a significant amount of damage
correct
yes through the course of yeah on which
day okay and you were you the scene was
chaos correct
chaos I mean there was a a fair amount
of damage the house was wrecked
there was a lot of damage in the house
yes and the house was not in a good
State correct
Aspen down there was a lot of damage
throughout that you could object first
and then to have your objection
objection and it helps okay however will
the objection go ahead next question
okay
and
um there you said there was glass on the
floor correct
in a few areas mainly predominantly in
the bar yes down in the lower ground
floor correct okay and there was blood
on the walls correct
in various places the blood on the floor
Blood on the walls and there was blood
on the walls throughout the three
stories of the house isn't that right
um no I wouldn't say that was the extent
of it there were smears up the staircase
going up to the master from the main
level there was smears and drips on the
carpet so there were smears from the
master level up to the up to the bedroom
area
I mean it comes from the main level up
to the bedroom area is that right up to
the third floor yes like someone had
walked from the main floor up to the
bedroom speculation correct there was
blood going up the stairs up steps on
the staircase and some on the walls you
know doesn't he just know where it was
not how it got there as if someone was
walking from the main level up to the
master bedroom correct is that what the
blood was like yeah maybe I don't know
it okay go down I mean up or down
up from the main level to the third
floor correct correct yes
um
and you said the sofas were damaged is
that right
one sofa in that sitting room which was
just off the kitchen was quite an open
plan thing so off that there was a sofa
with a large TV on the wall mounted TV
in front of that sofa and the sofa was
on the main level correct correct just
by the the Main Kitchen exactly where
the sofa was damaged was that with with
what blood okay and the lights were
damaged
some lamps a couple of lamps yes
and there were bottles of alcohol in and
out of the fridge correct
sorry what do you mean did you see
bottles of alcohol in it in and out of
the fridge
yes in and out that was I don't I don't
completely understand what you mean I
saw that girl there was alcohol bottled
yes it was in the fridge I did you see
bottles inside the fridge did you see
bottles outside the fridge it's like the
way the guy's asking it is weird
ruined I mean there was a lot of damage
on the floor on the down in the bar area
and the staircase and
on the main floor area in the wood
wooden parquet floor correct and the
floors are going to have to be sanded
correct
I eventually got them sanded yes okay
and it took you were there I think you
testified it took you about 12 to 13
hours in the house cleaning up correct
correct okay okay and you said that
there was is it your testimony that you
didn't see any of the paintings damaged
the existing paintings from the the
owners from the house that no none of
them were damaged you didn't see any
paintings with a painting of a penis
drawn on it I did not and thankfully I
that was something I wouldn't didn't
have to replace
objection speculation it would be hard
to get a new penis painting on short
notice okay stop that's all right if you
stand we can see you better when you do
that okay I'll sustain the objection
next question okay
and you said that Jerry judge was at the
house correct correct and he's the head
of Mr deficit security correct correct
and Dr Kipper was at the house yes he
was and Debbie Lloyd was at the house as
well correct yes she was okay now you
understood that Mr judge saw scratches
on Miss Herbert on March 8th correct
objection hearsay speculation Foundation
all right
I'll sustainable yeah you got to sustain
that um
did you have the cleaning lady was going
to be coming to the house correct the
housekeeper can you imagine he's not
allowed to say what someone told him
because it's hearsay but then the same
people want him to say did you hear
about what someone else had said they
saw on weekends there was concern about
the cleaning lady coming to the house
and seeing everything that was in the
house correct objection speculation uh
Foundation that they call out if you can
answer it
thank you
uh concern sorry there was concern about
the cleaning lady coming to the house
and seeing all the damage that was that
would have been done correct I know that
when I left to fly to L.A with Miss
heard I told both the chef and the
housekeeper they didn't need to be
coming to the house um because we said
that essentially the principals weren't
there Mr debt wasn't there misheard was
obviously with me at that point so I
said they didn't need to to come to the
house
isn't it true that you told Mr judge
that you thought you could get the
cleaning lady to swear to Silence about
what the house looked like
production hearsay it's his own
statement
isn't it true that you told Mr judge
that you could thought you could get the
cleaning lady to swear The Silence about
what the house looked like
I think I probably made
a comment about you know I should just
come back and deal with this myself if
that's what you mean and just get
cleaned up and make sure that she
wouldn't say anything correct I don't
know should we trusted I trusted her and
the chef anyway it could
good team team members as the house
manager part of your job is to you said
you worked with um
high profile people correct
high profile High net worth I think is
what I actually said
would you agree that one part of your
job is to keep things discreet for your
clients of course it's part of my job
trust and discretion yeah and Mr Depp
was your client right
I've worked on an assignment on those
occasions yes so I was self-employed at
the time but in
March 8th 2015 in Australia Mr Depp was
your client correct correct essentially
yeah or was it like the studio both of
them the principles
okay and do you know how
who paid years for your services
as I said before I was paid through
Disney who were making the Pirates of
the Caribbean their production company
which I believe was called her shell
okay and can we put up um defendants
exhibit 377.
um
which is already in evidence
Mr King DC defendants exhibit 377 in
front of you I do yes
and do you recognize this as a lampshade
that was in the house in Australia on
March 8th 2015.
yes it was I believe one of the lamp
shades that was missing from one of the
lamps okay and and you saw did you see
this uh painting on the on the lampshade
I did yeah it was part of my walk around
and what floor was the lampshade on this
was on where the art studio was on that
main level yeah so on the main level
okay yes
um
excuse me and was this it was this uh
did you notice it was dark paint that
was on the lampshade
certainly looked like it yes okay
okay um and did you take this picture
I believe I did yeah without seeing the
metadata but okay and can we put up
defendants exhibit 374 please
yeah
and you recognize
uh defendants exhibit 374 as a mirror
that was in the house in Australia on
March 8 2015 correct
yes I do
and this mirror was in the bathroom
correct
correct there were two berries in the
bathroom above each sink and this was on
the top floor correct the master
bathroom essentially and the master
bathroom just so unclear was on the top
floor right full correct and this uh
painting said starring Billy Bob is is
that right is that what you recall well
um
but yeah I don't know I was writing okay
um and was this in was this in uh the
writing was it in paint
I believe it was the same
paint the oil paint that was used on the
other mirror that we saw earlier okay
hey did you take this picture
again possible I I haven't seen the
metadata but yes probably and and let's
put back up uh defendants exit at 375.
this this writing was on was also in the
master bathroom correct correct yeah
okay and could you tell if the black
paint was on top of the red or or
under the red
I didn't really analyze it to be honest
I just knew I was going to have to clean
it up at some point right your whole
concern was just cleaning up cleaning up
the house correct correct okay
and you don't know who wrote what on
this on the mirror correct no I know
that one was oil painted and the other
red writing was lipstick and lipstick
you're not even sure of that you just
thought it was something sticky is that
right I'm pretty sure it's waxy you know
like lipstick like
um same as the oil paint was
oil paint like okay
did you see paint did you see also any
writing in blood
um writing not no not necessarily okay
now
did you help when when misheard was um
leaving to go
um
back to LA uh you were you were with her
correct correct did you help her pack
I think I may have done at that point
yes I think I did did you see were
weren't Miss hurts clothes ruined
well I didn't see any ruined clothes it
wasn't paint on her clothes
well I could see not so much
um yeah not not at that point of packing
I mean there was paint in the top
correct very good there was paint in the
tub in the bathroom correct I don't
recall that you don't recall one way or
the other
and it recalled being paint in the tub
and it's your testimony that there was
no pain or blood on Miss hurt's clothes
is that what you're saying okay
now
um
you were you said you were in charge of
the cleanup correct
yes it was my responsibility the house
was
and you were working with
Mr with Mr judge and
um cleaning up the house is that right
oh and then the night that I the day
that I arrived there yeah since the
judge did help me at some point yes
sweeping up glass Etc
and we're that we're there with our
photos taken of more than the three
things three pictures you've been shown
photos photos of the house
by whom did you take any pictures of the
house I took a few yeah I mean that yes
and uh did you take pictures other than
the three that we saw
I think I probably did as I was going
around do you know who you gave those
pictures to
no do you know what you took the photos
with
my phone and who would you have sent
those photos to and send them to anybody
at that point you just kept them
yes could you show the photos to anyone
good luck do you still have the photos
yes they're on they're where they're on
your phone still
they're on one of my devices yes okay
did you take a photo of the vodka bottle
that you said was broken
yes and you have that photo
yes okay and you didn't but you didn't
give that to anybody there were a fair
few photos I can show it to you now if
you want how many photos did you have on
your phone
I don't remember the number but I mean
probably more than 10.
did anyone ever ask you for the photos
several of them yes I was yes did you
give them to did you give them to the
people who asked
some of them yes not all of them I don't
recall how many who asked you for the
photos
um I was involved in in a case in London
a couple of years ago
did you give the photo of the vodka
bottle to the people
that you were involved in the case in
London attraction relevance your honor
wow
say again sorry did you give a photo of
the Baka bottle to the people you were
working with him vodka I didn't recall
which was photos I did
everything's allowed what other so did
you take photos of
um
the walls
the walls that certainly the smears of
the blood and the damage the plaster
would damage yes you took so you took
photos of the
walls with blood on it is that right
yes and you took photos of the plaster
right that was damaged
at the end of the bar under in the bar
behind the bar by the sink yes and did
you take photos of the um ping pong
table that you said was broken
yes as part of the bar area I'm sure
take photos of there was a glass table
that was broken too correct the class
table I don't recall it cost to you okay
did you take photos of all the damage
that was around the house
probably the most of it yes okay and
the only time you gave those photos to
anyone you're saying was in the UK case
a couple years back I'd never shared
them with anybody else yes okay
quite discreet he's a butler
and it costs between
it costs about seventy five thousand
dollars to clean up the damages is that
right
I don't know the exact cost I think we I
calculated at the time you know after
all the vendors had been in done their
things it's about 50 000 I seem to
recall
now
[Music]
you
you said you flew back to to Australia
with Miss hurt correct
I didn't fly back with me back to LA
from Australia you never said that we
miss heard correct correct okay
and you were asleep for most of the
flight correct a lot of it I think it's
a 14-hour flight so I think we both
slept for quite a lot of it yeah you
were exhausted from the 13 hours you
were working on the house right correct
all right and your testimony was that
misheard said to you have you ever been
so angry with someone that you just lost
it correct after I'd asked so you know
what happened but you didn't you you
didn't inquire as to what she was
referring to right
I mean by what happened it was pretty
clear what I was referring to
let me ask again you did not inquire as
to what she was referring to did you
with her answer correct
she didn't inquire as to my reason for
asking but it was pretty obvious to both
of us what I was asking and what her
reply was regarding
it's like we both knew what we were
talking about sir
the reason we're on this plane together
right now
the butler's doing quite well I must say
thank you
thanks Charles Whitney for grabbing a
membership on my website appreciate that
Mr King you testified on behalf of Mr
death in the UK correct
correct
okay and you provided two witness
statements correct
correct and then you provided testimony
in court correct
correct okay
and if you take a look
at
page 1103 of your testimony
you see how the pages go in fours yeah
no
you see it's actually on the bottom
right
at the bottom right you see that yeah I
got it
and if you actually look at
um
you see it's starting at the bottom of
1102
there's this was a statement when you
said you did not
um
you say misheard asked you have you ever
been so angry with anyone that you've
lost it your answer that's correct
and you specifically remember that do
you yes you said it never happened to
you
answer that is correct question she did
not I mean
it was if it was said nothing was said
about who she was talking about was it
answer she was asking me a question a
question she was asking you a question
answer yes question you did not inquire
as to what she was referring to did you
I did not I do not recall asking I know
that she was asking it for a question
and I gave her an answer
yes okay and that was your testimony you
gave in the UK uh two years ago oh God
yes okay
so you don't know what and you don't
know what Miss heard was talking about
when she made that statement correct it
was obvious
you don't know if she was inquiring that
she was making that statement about Mr
Beck right we both knew that I'd ask the
question what happened referring to the
house
um and she gave me that answer so I
think we were both
it was pretty clear to both of us what
we were talking about I mean you want to
say at that point and then you went and
then you went to sleep and then you had
the flight the rest of it sometime after
that yeah okay
um
now
and you said you saw misheard with cuts
on her arm is that right
um right towards the end of the flight
yeah okay
if we could put up 376 G
not true you had airplane coffee
do you recognize
this picture
I've not seen this picture before were
these the were these the cuts did you
see Cuts Like This on Miss heard
is that misheard why don't we put out
376 C
do you deny you asked for the kosher
meal do you recognize the person in that
picture
that's misheard all right and did you
see Cuts Like That which are on her left
arm
similar to that long like I described
earlier long thin cuts
um pretty uniform Cuts these were the
cut it was the cuts were like this on
her kind of wrist forearm area is that
right I don't know what the date of this
photograph is but they look pretty
uniform like they do here yes okay
okay like to enter 376c into evidence
see in evidence
with them
and can we this is a crazy trial really
nuts
the butler to me is the star of this
whole thing
is it true you kept the contest slippers
is this consistent with the scratches on
376g are these consistent with the
scratches you saw in this heard
I don't see a date is that the same time
is that the same date I mean my question
is are the scratches similar to what you
saw in miss her
these are uniform kind of long thin
scratches yes
through 76g and evidence any objection
like Foundation he hasn't authenticated
the document through this Witness
I mean I'm just asking if the pictures
are consistent
and can you publish it please it is
thank you there's a good question here
from people saying Johnny Depp's suing
for 50 million does she even have 50
million my understanding is he has 150
million and she has 8 million but that
that may not be accurate
okay
now you were in the
house you said for 12 to 13 hours on
March 8th 2015 correct
correct going into March 9th 2015.
and you spoke to Mr judge when you were
in the house correct
you had interaction with Mr judge yes
and you had interaction with Dr Kipper
when you were in the house correct
correct and you had interaction with
Debbie Lloyd when you're in the house
correct yes briefly
and isn't it true that in the entire
time you were there you were not
informed as to
what caused damage to Mr def's Hand on
finger on March 8th objection hearsay
beautiful he wasn't told
I'll sustain the objection next question
you didn't know what could cause damage
to Mr def's Hand while you were there on
March 8th correct Dr kid would have told
me but you don't know what caused the
injury one of his fingers
I don't think anybody mentioned it to me
at that time right no one mentioned it
to you at that time correct
hearsay
sorry I'll loud next question
we answered it
now you understand that there was
um
a phone in the house that was recording
during the cleanup correct sorry I
didn't hear all of that did you come to
understand that there was a phone in the
house that was recording as people were
cleaning up
um at that time no but you now you now
know that there was a phone that was
recording people as they were cleaning
up correct objection Foundation hearsay
all right I'm not asking for particular
statements that's just fine how loud if
he knows
I believe that came up somewhere later
on at that time I wasn't aware but I
believe I became aware of it later yes
okay
um I would like to
um
uh put up uh
defendants 378 it's a recording
and I want to play a couple of times
oh boy 1207
through 13 19.
about a minute and 12 seconds
only segment you wish to have
and then I would also use I'd also like
to play 1951 through 2138 and
um I I think it would be a okay 378 any
objection of 378 a yes here on our we do
have an objection I believe this is a
recording that has the voices of people
other than misheard and Mr Devin on that
basis it's hearsay okay unless I'm
incorrect about which document we're
talking about please proceed Governor
I'm sure
all right guys at this time my coverage
has to end because I actually have to
get set up for our later stream I'm
going to be streaming streaming the Dr
Mehmet Oz debate later
um so there are any number of other
streams that will continue
um thank you for joining me and I will
be back with everybody in a couple of
hours see you very soon